also humiliating by the way
new interview
on the anniversary of 9 11 the 21st
anniversary of 9 11 which was over the
weekend
republican
senate nominee in georgia herschel
walker appeared on fox news's program
with maria bartoromo
and he tried to make a statement about
the 21st anniversary of 9 11
and it was completely unintelligible and
confusing very shaky
the entire interview was very shaky he
is now winning in more polls walker is
now ahead of warnock in georgia and look
at how he can't even make sense of
anything
well you know you got to pay tribute to
the 9 11 victims uh you know but also
you saw america come together you saw
america come together because this
country was uh you know it was uh on the
war with uh
a country that didn't believe in us and
right what
this country was on the war against the
country that didn't believe in us and
then the country came together
does he think that
the iraq war was related to 911 even
though that's been widely debunked for
decades
does he think that the war
was with a different country it's not
clear what he's talking about now we
have uh leaders in washington like joe
biden doing venomous speeches right that
doesn't believe in american people
right so walker continuing to really
struggle to make any sense walker at one
point raised the great maya angelou
and um
try to
use language that certainly would make
maya angelou
uh up in the heavens roll her eyes i'm
sure for this country i'm fighting for
georgia because if we give up that seat
and i know maya angelou said it when you
see what when somebody tells you who
they are believe them right now since
rafael went up been in office we got
higher taxes we got higher gas prices
got the economy has gone is is terrible
right we have almost full employment
we have gas prices seeing one of their
fastest declines in a long time the gas
price increase had nothing to do with
warnock the gas price decrease has
nothing to do with warnock um and then
as far as taxes going up there just
there has not been uh tax reform where
quote taxes have gone up in the in the
vague and overarching way that herschel
walker is talking about just none of it
makes sense during the same interview
walker saying 70 of drugs go through
atlanta georgia tell me about the issues
and what needs to be done regarding the
border and crime
well one of the things that people don't
know georgia is not a border state but
seven percent of the drugs coming into
this country goes through atlanta
georgia and that's something that my
opponent don't want to address well he's
not addressing it because there's no
evidence that it's true it's really
unclear what walker means by seventy
percent of drugs coming into this
country go through atlanta i researched
it under any of its possible meanings i
was unable to verify that claim does he
mean that the seventy percent of drugs
are coming through the atlanta airport
which is a major airport
does he mean that 70 of the drugs are
being driven through atlanta georgia on
the roads
by no
possible definition was i able to verify
that
and then lastly
walker with
i think that this is a transphobic
statement but it's not even really clear
that's something that my opponent don't
want to address you don't want to
address the border have you noticed that
it seemed like everyone on the left
don't want to address the problem this
economy crime they don't want to address
uh they don't address men and women in
sports they don't want to address
they're even talking about regular to
talk about whether a man can get
pregnant that's not important right yeah
uh he really has a way with words but i
don't know what the hell he's talking
about and he is increasingly winning
winning his race
can you believe that if we look at the
latest polling data the last three polls
have walker ahead
the last three polls have walker ahead
this is a guy who should have zero
percent support
but our electorate
and particularly the electorates of
states like georgia to some degree
particularly among republicans in
georgia
horrifying
weaponized propagandized individuals
it's scary stuff extraordinarily scary
stuff the david pakman show's longest
running sponsor is blinkist the app that
takes thousands of non-fiction books
boils each of them down into an
explainer you can read or listen to in
15 minutes blinkist also condenses
episodes of popular podcasts into 15
minute explainers i've been using
blinkist for years to supplement the
books i read i love reading i i read all
the time but there's even more books i
don't have time to read and you can
often find those non-fiction books on
blinkist and consume the entire thing in
15 minutes my favorite new feature on
the app is blinkist connect which lets
you share your blinkist premium account
with someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert green's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below